Oh,
so this is where free and open source software is just essential.
Like the big networks,
there's no excuse for them not to be sharing their software.
Right.
It's like when you're a public forum on that scale,
the community just has a right to know what the algorithms are doing.
So you think that they're not sharing their software because their software is
encoded in designed to spy on you and extract information and sell that
information?
Partially like when Jamie gives up your contacts,
when he signs up for an APP and he says,
yes,
you can get access to all my contacts.
There's a lot of reason and they don't want people to compete with them.
Like anyone could actually take all of our code and make their own social
network and compete with us.
They could set up on their own servers and we encourage that.
That's what like the Fed averse is called.
That's what Elon Musk does with Tesla,
all of his electric patents for electric cars.
I think that he opened up the pants.
I don't think if he,
he opened sourced all the,
the code of the car.
Right.
He's definitely in moving in the right direction of like he wants to build the
market.
Yes.
And he also wants to save the world.
I mean he legitimately has any,
also has a shitload of money and was kind enough plumbing.
Yeah.
That's,
I think that's a big factor with those guys.
But don't you think that it's almost like it's going to help whatever network
does that Oh,
is more transparent,
stop spying on people.
Is More community run and evolved?
Wouldn't that be the network that you would think humanity would want to stick
with in the longterm?
Like wouldn't that be a good move of them?
Yes and no.
For the average person,
what are they losing when they get on Facebook or Google?
What are the,
what's bad?
What happened?
Now their legs are going down,
everybody's likes are going down.
And that makes everyone very sad.
What do you mean will the algorithms,
you're only reaching 5% of your own followers organically on Facebook now.
And they're starting to change the chronological feed on Instagram too.
And they know that this causes depression and they're still doing it because
they know that the,
you know,
they're,
they think they're better at showing you what you want to see than you are and
they want to make money from it.
What do you mean by they know that this causes depression?
They've done studies about mental health in relation to,
actually Facebook got exposed like five years ago for doing a secret study on
like a few million users where they were injecting both positive and negative
content into the newsfeed and they proved that they could affect people's moods.
This was with Princeton,
there's a huge backlash and they're like,
oh,
sorry.
Whoops.
Right,
but this isn't a injecting negative or positive content.
This is just moving these images or these posts around so that less people see
them.
There's two different topics there.
The basic news feed on Facebook is now a mysterious conglomeration of thousands
of variables,
which we don't know.
And,
but additionally,
like a few years ago,
they were exposed for having been experimenting with people's brains.
That's right.
I remember that now.
I remember that now that,
that that's right.
Yeah.
I remember thinking like,
wow,
that's kinda creepy.
[inaudible]
the people that are on their site and they're not telling these people that are
experimenting on them.
Yeah.
But do they,
I mean,
if they're trying to make it better,
um,
do you think that they're really,
that's a factor that it actually,
it actually could.
I mean,
how does it cause depression if they're just,
if your images or your posts are not being seen as by as many people have you
talked to kids posting on social media and their reactions to how many likes
they're getting,
they get very,
very,
um,
concerned.
Well that seems like more of a problem with that.
It is both.
It's not,
it is on both sides being addicted to likes as some sort of,
uh,
you know,
to weird dopamine.
Yeah.
Right.
It's not healthy and we need to learn to not care about that.
But I think that the core purpose of the social network is to subscribe to
someone and see their stuff.
And when people subscribe to you,
they see your stuff.
Right?
So when you spend years building up a following on social media and say earn
100,000 followers or something and then suddenly the network says,
hmm Nah,
now your friends can't see that anymore.
That's not cool.
And,
and even like Twitter's default newsfeed is no longer chronological.
You have to click it to go chronological and then it defaults back to their
weird algorithm thing.
So we're saying look,
100% organic,
chronological,
raw forever as default.
And then if you want to curate,
you know,
algorithms or have recommended stuff come in as a alternative,
fine.
But that is the core purpose of social media is to connect with people that
follow you and the other way around.
What do you think the purpose is?
Like why do you think Facebook would decide to have things not in chronological
order and only be seen by 5% of your followers?
Like what will it be the benefit of that for them?
Revenue.
How so?
How's that generate revenue?
They just know that they can keep you on the app better if you had less likes.
No.
If your your stuff seen by less people,
it doesn't make sense.
That's a good point.
It sort of works both ways.
I think that they think they know the people that you're going to react to the
most.
So as a consumer,
when you're getting that content,
you know the algorithms are showing you what you typically like.
Have you noticed that?
I'm really not paying much attention but I don't believe you.
So yeah,
for Creator it's hurting creators.
People who post are getting hurt.
People who are sitting there just scrolling.
They're the ones who are really getting addicted more so with the algorithms.
So how are the people that are posting getting hurt?
They're getting hurt because their stuff is being seen by last people.
Yeah,
because it's not chronological and it's an organic cause.
It's curated.
Huh?
But aren't they doing it because they think it's going to be a better and
unexperienced?
It's more conducive to your life.
That's what they say.
What do you think they're doing it for then?
They're doing it because they have studied through looking at the data,
how to keep people on the APP more.
Right?
And that way is to give them like say if I Google or if I look at muscle cars on
Instagram now if I go to my search,
it's all muscle car stuff.
So that's what it is.
They say,
oh,
he likes that.
So we're going to,
we're just going to give him a lot of that and I think that's okay as an
alternative feed or to put that somewhere.
I just think the core feed always needs to stay pure.
Hmm.
Because otherwise you're just down the slippery slope again and understand just
feeding their,
they're injecting things into your head that you didn't ask for it.
Right.
And they're doing it because they want to keep you around.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Um,
how many different companies are subscribing to that is,
it seems like all the big ones were saying are curating and moving things around
and all the big ones have an algorithm that's designed to keep you on board.
Right.
And that's okay to pursue.
I think there's really cool things you can do with AI and machine learning and
algorithms that is really beneficial,
but it's just taking away people's reach when they have worked years and years
to achieve it.
It's not okay.
Do you think that this is this marriage between something that is this social
media network that's designed to allow people to communicate with each other and
then commerce like this business,
like how do we maximize this business?
How do we get more profit out of this business?
How do we get these people to engage more?
And then they start monkeying with the code and screwing with what you see and
what you don't say.
You think that's what's happening?
Yeah,
but in the short term it's probably working,
but in the long term they're betraying everybody's trust.
It has to be more of a consent based system.
So you know,
at least give people,
well it should be a opt out by default and find,
give me messages to opt in so that you can show me certain things.
But this whole force forcing people into surveillance is,
it just has to stop.
It's,
it's super scary.
How's it super security you?
It's just too much power.
Mm.
Yeah.
It's too much power for something that supposed to be silly,
right?
Like what was Facebook supposed to do?
Supposed to be some silly thing that you just can communicate with friends.
It was,
but from the beginning,
all of these,
none of these networks I've ever really been about the people of the networks.
It's always been closed source since the inception.
So,
but then you look at open networks out there,
you have Wikipedia,
totally open source community.
Ryan granted they have their issues with moderation.
Fine.
But it's a top 10 website in the world is totally open sores,
creative Commons content,
incredible human achievement,
bitcoin,
open source money.
Wordpress even is an open source CMS system that is like powering 25% of the
Internet.
So why when that happened with social media it should,
I mean this is where Mons hanging out.
So we should all sort of collectively even own it.
We did a an equity crowd funding round.
So like thousands members of our community actually own the site.
Hm.
Now,
how many people are on machines?
We have like a million and a half registered,
like quarter million active.
Various we're,
we're,
we're small.
But the weird thing is that even though we're a fraction of the size,
especially smaller creators who come get better reach on minds than they do on
Facebook and Twitter because we have this reward and incentive system sort of
like gamified where you earn reach and you earn more of a voice for
contributing.
So like you could have a account on Twitter for 10 years in post thousands and
thousands of tweets and you never hit that viral nerve and you just never,
never really get much exposure.
So we're trying to help people be heard.
And so you'll find a small creator who on other networks has no followers,
have thousands and thousands of followers on mines.
And what do you think you would like to do with mines in the future that you
haven't been able to do yet?
Engineer the control out of ourselves so that we aren't even in a position to
really,
you know,
take people stuffed down or what if someone posts your house and your
information where your kids go to school?
I think that on the central servers obviously yes,
we're always going to moderate and if it's legal it can stay.
If it's not illegal it can't.
But
a decentralized social network is definitely where we have to go because,
and yeah.
Okay.
It's,
it's scary.
And you know,
you've talked about this,
like things are getting more transparent our lives.
It's sort of like the inevitable evolution of technology.
I mean,
how many hours a day do you stream a couple,
you know,
25 years ago would you have thought you'd be sharing,
20% of your life live streaming to,
you know,
millions of people like you're,
our lives are becoming more transparent.
Just inevitably it's just pulling us.
Yeah,
I agree.
So you know,
Bitcoin Crypto,
dat torrent,
Stipe,
torrent type architecture,
that is just where we're going because it's more resilient,
it's less censorship prone,
there's just benefits of it.
I think that we can balance it to like maybe when you post,
you have a decision,
do you want to be able to delete this at any point?
All right,
fine.
Then you can post the central server.
Do you want this to get unleashed?
Yeah.
It's scary because,
you know,
they're scary stuff on the Internet.
It's already like that.
But,
you know,
getting into censorship more.
Does censorship even solve the problem or does it make it worse?
What problem?
The problem of crazy content,
illegal content does it,
how could it make it worse?
Well,
I mean,
it seems like it can often amplify radicalization.
The definitely can,
right?
Yeah.
And it definitely,
um,
when you censor people,
it just makes them aware that there's plot against them too.
Right?
It's a lot of conservatives on Twitter filing that.
Somebody us,
Sam Harris actually just sent me an article.
Um,
there was a detailing the bias against conservatives on Twitter that they've
actually done,
you know,
like some real studying it and it's pretty demonstrated [inaudible] demonstrably
it affects both the left and the right rail,
demonstrably.
Yeah.
The way I'm saying it wrong.
Um,
but it's,
it affects the left than the right.
For sure.
Yeah,
that's what Kyle was saying.
I watched that video that he did and he's antiestablishment that seems to be
getting targeted.
And so,
you know,
Abby's been censored on face and being going to learn.
Um,
and yeah,
this person today that,
I mean,
most of the stuff coming out of our t is progressive,
which is weird.
And who knows what kind of games are getting played behind the scenes with the
rush.
I mean,
who knows?
But the point is they have a right to be there.
And I mean,
look at,
this is not youtube fault,
but remember the youtube shooter,
I mean she thought she was getting censored on Youtube and she went and brought
a gun to the youtube headquarters.
Like people get pissed when they get censored.
It affects you.
Right.
But in her case,
you're talking about a crazy person that loves being sensory people out there.
Yeah,
no,
she,
she wasn't being,
she was getting censored just like everybody else is getting soft censored on
these networks.
Well,
she just thought wasn't,
she didn't,
wasn't getting promoted the way she wanted to wait.
I don't think anybody was actively doing anything at all.
I'm not saying that her stuff was 10 saying that the soft censorship of the
algorithms,
people getting demonetized this has an impact on psychology.
Okay.
I see what you're saying.
So it's,
I'm not saying they were deliberately targeting her and it's horrible what
happened,
but
yeah.
Mm.
So what you're saying is that these algorithms that they use in order to
maximize their revenue and give people things that they like,
but actually takes away from things being posted chronologically,
keep certain things from being seen by as many people.
So it keeps him from being as viral,
so keeps the whole thing from being ordered organic.
Yeah.
Makes Sense.
It's,
uh,
it gets to that point where we're realizing that all of these things,
all these social media things are really recent.
We've only had them for a few years and we don't necessarily know what the rules
should or shouldn't be.
So it's good.
I mean,
this is one of the reasons why I wanted to have you on.
I wanted to find out where these upstarts,
where these new people are coming into the game,
like minds,
like where you're coming into the game from and what,
what is your position on?
What's wrong with the current state of affairs?
Yeah.
Look,
there is messed up stuff on social media.
Like I'm not,
we'll get pigeonholed into being like,
oh,
you support all of this,
this crazy stuff.
First of all,
most of the users on mines are like artists,
musicians,
filmmakers,
activists,
journalists.
Just trying to get their content out there.
There's a very tiny minority of like actually,
you know,
crazy content.
But when you say crazy content,
what do you mean?
You all right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Or I mean,
I'm not even going to make decisions on what is and isn't crazy.
That's not,
that's not my place,
but
the,
it's been proven that censorship is not the answer.
I mean to look at the history of prohibition.
Okay.
Yes.
It's,
it's you have digital content,
it's substances,
it's,
it's anything in from,
people want information.
They want the ability to make the decision for themselves.